and speaking of mistakes there's
definitely one here in the timeline
during the autopsy of John Kramer an
autopsy is usually performed the next
day after a death and thanks to St and
Hoffman being collected by ambulances
they would have found Kramer and the
other bodies immediately so one would
assume that Jon's autopsy would occur
the next day April 29th 2006 right the
problem is that the date on John's
autopsy tag is October 21st 2006 when
the FBI agent stum comes snooping
Hoffman fittingly wearing a pig mask
sneaks up behind him and gives him the
old needle and puts him into the water
Cube trap it doesn't take 6 months to do
an autopsy and judging by the lack of
decomposition on Jon's body it hasn't
been very long since he died so the
October 21st tag doesn't make any sense
maybe Logan Nelson's cousin was in
charge of putting the tags on and uh
just put the wrong date or something